le débat est récurrent depuis plusieurs
années maintenant malheureusement entre
le voile islamique à l'école les signes
religieux apparents pourquoi pas non
plus le retour de l'uniforme dans les
écoles en tout cas ce qu exige de plus
en plus de directeur d'établissement
c'est une tenue correcte à l'entrée pas
de casquette de travers ou de nombril à
l'air reportage dans un collège du 12e
arrondissement de paris nabila taboury
et jean françois manier
joué au top model lisa et sa copine
célia adore nouveau pantalon dernier tee
shirt à la mode 80 euros par mois c'est
tout l'argent de poche qui passe en
vêtements mais quand il s'agit du
collège ne de lolita très sage ne se
permettent pas tout
je vais mettre cette tenue au collège
parce que premièrement il ya on voit mon
bras et si je préfère les manchots
simple normal il ya un décolleté le
pantalon je peux pas le mettre non plus
parce qu'il ya on voit mon nombril comme
ça là
bas je trouve qu'il ya un peu beaucoup
de paillettes
et la couleur elle est un peu ça fait un
peu d'amis je trouve et les cables aussi
montre oui les tailles basses ah oui ça
là cette sagesse vestimentaire lisa la
doit aussi à sa maman tél moi je fais
attention à ses tenues oui mais je
saurai ce qu'il met
tous les matins à l'entrée du collège le
principal veille depuis quinze jours
tenue correcte exigée
par exemple on n'aime pas trop les
casquettes
bonjour les adultes font la chasse aux
strings et qu'elles sont qui dépasse
depuis qu'ils ont remarqué quelques abus
on estime que dans telle communauté
scolaire on doit pas être comme à la
plage ou com
en
baissant la direction du collège
rappelle aux élèves et aux familles qu
une tenue décente exigé à l'intérieur de
l'interdiction mêmes officiels une note
dans le carnet de correspondance signée
par tous les parents dans le collège la
mesure n'a pas fait de vagues mais les
avis sont très partagés
je trouve qu'ils abusent et un peu quand
même parce que moi je trouve pas qu'il y
en ait qui qui s'habille vraiment vieux
garland c'est normal on n'a pas montré
notre caleçon ni i nostri va sûrement
être notre call sonaca venu en cachons
sont elles en t-shirt ou cachés par un
gilet lequel son illustre in se font
désormais plus discret avec l'hiver on
ne les verra plus un long répit qu'on la
direction du collège avant le retour des
beaux jours et puis une guéguerre qui
pourrait faire école au lycée de
ribeauvillé l'administration est parti
en guerre contre le port du débardeur
qui laisse le nombril à l'air et contre
le string qui dépasse du pantalon taille
basse et cela au grand dam des élèves
qui bien sûr se rebelle reportage
stéphane rodrigues higway dans les rues
touristiques de ribeauvillé la vie
s'écoule paisiblement au rythme des
randonneurs qui g vers les monts
d'alsace pourtant au pied des vignes sur
les hauteurs de la ville la polémique
agite le lycée ribeaupierre objet de
cette polémique les quelques centimètres
qui séparent parfois l'eau jean dumas
d'un tee shirt armée du règlement
intérieur qui exige des élèves une tenue
correcte et décente les professeurs
entendent bannière de l'enceinte de
l'établissement
les nombres et les strings affiché au
grand jour réactions mitigées des
principales intéressées
ce thème des bilans
l'enseignement et c'est clair qu'il faut
pas abuser quoi c'est pas pour choquer
qu'on fait ça donc si on mois ci si on
monte notre nombril c'est juste parce
qu'il faisait chaud et qu'on avait chaud
et c'est tout ce n'était pas pour
montrer notre nombril déjà il y en a pas
beaucoup qui le voyaient bon bien sûr il
ya toujours des élèves qui a buzzé qui
met des trucs choquant dans ce lycée où
l'on avait déjà exclu il ya trois ans
deux élèves coupables de s'embrasser on
insiste sur la nécessité de fixer des
limites et d'affirmer l'autorité des
adultes mais si le proviseur
s'enorgueillit du soutien de ses
collègues de la région au sein de
l'équipe enseignante certains jugent un
peu déplacé l'obsession de décence qui
embrase le lycée heureusement le
changement de saison il devrait avoir
raison des strings le nombril
[Musique]